armed soldiers on the move in bogota
patrolling crime hot spots in the city
checking identities and frisking
passersby freely
the deployment of hundreds of soldiers
in colombia's main cities followed an
appeal from mayor claudia lopez to the
national government
this is not a militarization of the city
but it is convenient for the army to
support the police in two tasks
dissuading crime and searching for
weapons
while critics say the measure is
dangerous and unconstitutional some
believe it's a necessary evil
it's a difficult situation there is lots
of theft a lack of security so i think
it's good
robberies and violent crimes have seen a
sharp upward spike since the economy
started to recover after months of
coronavirus confinement so far this year
the city has registered
754 murders a 15.7 percent increase and
more than 65 000 robberies but what
worries the most authorities is the
level of violence
fifteen-year-old laura morales was shot
in the legs at close range by a thief
despite giving up her phone
it's crazy to attack a defenseless child
i can understand mugging an adult but
now they are shooting kids i can't
understand how anyone could do that
the situation has become so dangerous
that some banks are offering insurance
to protect atm withdrawals
[Music]
for less than two dollars you're
protected for two hours in case of
robbery it covers the money but also
violent debt
domestic military deployment remains
controversial in a country just emerging
from decades of war when soldiers were
deployed with the police in may in
response to anti-government protest it
sparked international condemnation when
dozens were killed
experts say that repeated studies in
latin american cities show that
deploying the army does not improve
security
what it shows is the inability of the
local and national government to manage
security policies properly and it shows
that nobody prepared for a wave of crime
so strong as the one we're dealing with
the pandemic has increased poverty
levels in colombia to more than 40
percent and nearly one in five people is
unemployed a desperate situation for
many and few believe soldiers on the
street as anything more than a temporary
solution alessandra ampietti al jazeera
bogota